nos encontramos en la población de
arriba a 60 kilómetros al sur de savory
allá en la vía a melitópol una gran
ciudad en el sur que ya está en control
de las fuerzas rusas y esta población
está también bastante cerca de estas
fuerzas enemigas que controlan los
pueblos aledaños y constantemente atacan
esta población este edificio a mis
espaldas fue atacado el pasado
domingo al menos dos personas murieron
otros más quedaron heridos y la parte de
la población que vivía todavía aquí
cogió buses humanitarios y huyó rumbo a
saponi ya esa población que hoy recoge a
la mayoría de personas desplazadas del
sur inclusive incluso ido mariupol sin
embargo aquí nos cuentan las personas
que se quedaron que quieren hacerlo
porque no quieren ser desplazados la
mayoría de ellos son personas mayores
que viven de su pensión y no tienen
ningún apoyo familiar sin embargo
también nos dicen que si las fuerzas
rusas llegarán a acercarse aún más ellos
buscarían la manera de huir del lugar